so you're on a role with this shaft and
yet yeah you hated the director John
Singleton is that true or false that's
false that is false you will work with
him again you fighting with him so much
that was a whole creative kind of uh
chaos sometimes that was you know kind
of kind of going on because you had the
producers who had one idea about what
shaft is was should be then you had John
who was like a three-year-old kid when
he saw it and then you had me who
thought he could be sha because I was
basically 20 years old when saw it right
and shaft would to me is it shouldn't be
Superman he's just a guy who's very very
capable who was up against a lot of
tough situations and managed to somehow
uh Prevail yeah had some very good
Street smarts was very cool had some you
know Mac ability with the ladies and you
didn't want to make it a cartoon
character and they did exactly I I now I
haven't read anything about this but I'm
assuming that an older guy would see
that in Che so how do you uh get them to
do the right thing right you don't you
um try to be as diplomatic about it as
possible in most instances in most
instances and then sometimes you know
things happen where you got to say hey
man I'm not doing that uh and you say
well let's just shoot it this way try it
this way give me an example in other
words the director come to you and say I
want you to do something that I that
they don't want you to do what do they
ask you to
do well we had some gunfight scenes
where when I finally find Tony Colette
the girl that I've been looking for the
whole movie um
this gunfight breaks out and they said
hide the girl and then kill all these
guys and come back and get her I I've
been looking for this girl the whole
movie am I going to hide the last thing
I want to do is let her go she ran away
from me for 2 years so you go I'm not
letting her go yeah but you're having a
gunfight okay so I start killing people
with them and then in fact when you want
to impress the chick how good you are
with your gun and let her see you kill
the guy exactly and then the dead guy
goes down I want to pick up his gun they
go no leave that there I'm why why would
you leave his gun there's like 13 bad
guys out here I got 12 bullets there's
an extra gun right here I'm picking this
gun up okay so in a sense you're telling
me you were thinking things through and
they W they exactly and when a movie
like that is number one at the box
office good for you this is real good
for you this means that you are going to
be able to raise your price per film
yeah and you will be seen now as a true
leading man one who can play opposite
women you can get the girl you can be
you will be an action hero it's funny I
we saw Samuel at a screening of a movie
Once yes and we said Sam you got to do
the show because I'm not famous enough
you said I'm not large enough yet so now
you are I guess now you're large enough
yeah there you
go